I want to congratulate you
Golden Globe nomination for theory of
everything which is a terrific movie
[Applause]
you look gorgeous at the on the red
carpet and at the Globes was it a fun
event it was I mean it was an amazing
event you've been before the big deal
yeah this year though nothing for me
well what a sore subject goddamn but it
was it was actually very hot so I was a
lot of it I was trying to you know it
was a lot about sweat control because
that you start the night off and you
spend hours getting ready and you're you
know you're doing your hair and makeup
and you and you're really nervous and
then and then by the end of the night
literally my makeup was like sliding
down my face the heat your your hair's
like all over the place this you're
trying to you know talk to someone who
you've admired for years and then
there's sweat dripping down your back so
it was it was it was a pretty intense
ordeal they couldn't afford air
conditioning at the Golden Globes maybe
it wasn't what I spend on liquor know if
it's the only it's the only award show
that they really encourage lots of
drinking like it doesn't happen there's
no drinking really at the Emmys there's
no drinking at the Oscars but at the
Golden Globes no one eats they give you
a ton of liquor and then they just see
what happens yeah and then animate the
room really hot at the same time
you